hi my name is Sarah Goodwin and we're
here today with dr. David Morgan who is
a professor at the University of
California San Francisco and Dave is an
avid book collector so thank you for
joining us my pleasure we'll start with
how did you begin collecting books well
it started many many moons ago I mean I
was doing it when I was a kid actually
and I used to go to the used bookstores
in my hometown all the time even when I
was in my early teens and I was clearly
fairly obsessed with them right from the
early days and so I've always been
interested in books the last 15 or 20
years is when I really gotten going on
that on the important old stuff that I
have now how big is your current
collection I'm not at liberty to say my
wife thinks it's way too big that's all
I can say it's huge I have hundreds of
things I have boxes in most closets I
have shelves and also in most rooms in
the house and so it's it's a bit out of
control and in fact I've in the last few
years I've really tried to get a little
more focused and just get a few good
things instead of filling things up with
a lot of bad things and so but it is I
don't know hundreds thousands maybe what
types of books did you collect when you
were younger um well believe it or not
my dad was an airplane mechanic and so I
was heavily into airplanes and so I I
love books about World War two airplanes
when I was a teenager so I have stacks
of those in my basement that I still
have
but then as as the years went by I
became interested in a lot of other
things as well what was your first big
find oh well I mean there was this
transition period back in the mid 90s
when I became serious and realized I
could get the really old interesting
original things from hundreds of years
ago and and so in a way those early
those early books that I got at that
stage were kind of a highlight in a way
because it was all new and exciting in
and I thought it was really fun to have
a book that was 400 or 300 years old
although in retrospect what I was buying
back then was completely was really not
very good stuff I didn't know what I was
doing
in those early days and so it took it
takes many years actually to learn what
to look for when looking for a book and
and collecting condition The Binding all
these other issues that you have to
think about so let's talk about some of
the books that you brought today yeah I
thought I'd bring along a few highlights
of one of the main interests of what I
do which is collecting books in the in
the history of cell division and and
basically going back to the 1700s or so
when when cells were first witnessed
through microscopes and other other
little optical instruments and and then
working up into the 1800s when the cell
theory came along and when people first
started realizing that cells reproduced
by division and and so there there are
dozens of great scientists involved in
this process of making it away from the
seventeen hundreds through to the
roughly late 1800s when all these things
were found and I can't possibly I have a
lot of their work at home but I couldn't
bring them all in but so what I did was
I brought a few the highlights the the
ones that kind of turned me on the most
and in a way a lot of people like to
start with with leave and hook they the
Dutch microscopist who first saw little
animals under the microscope and he saw
a lot of different organisms through his
microscope and little animals he called
them as I said and and in some cases he
may have been witnessing cell division
but he didn't really know what he was
looking at and in fact it's it's
unlikely he ever actually witnessed or
reported the division of a cell of a
single-celled animal and it wasn't until
a little later so he was in the late
sixteen hundreds early seventeen
hundreds
it wasn't until more like the middle of
the 1700s that people actually started
describing the division of single-celled
organisms and the first guy to do that
probably was this fellow from Geneva
called Abraham Tremblay and he he was a
really interesting character who grew up
in Geneva and then in his 20s moved to
Holland to become a tutor for the the
children of this this aristocrat who
lived on this giant estate in Holland
and
on that estate Tremblay basically taught
these two kids while at the same time
exploring the grounds of the estate and
exploring the water of those grounds and
finding little animals that lived in
there and then looking at them under a
magnifying glass essentially one of his
biggest discoveries was that he found
this little organism that we now call
Hydra which had been described
previously but not to the extent that he
did and in studying Hydra he was really
curious about whether Hydra was a plant
or an animal because it looked a little
like both and in one of his experiments
when he wanted to figure out if it was a
plant or an animal he decided well maybe
if he cut it in two
an animal would die probably whereas a
plant might continue to grow or or might
at least survive in some way but he was
absolutely shocked because when he cut
hydron into two parts the two halves
regenerated to form two whole organisms
which then moved to moved around like
animals and so it became clear that
Hydra was an animal that could be cut in
half and regenerated and that was a
mind-boggling result at the time and
when word started spreading he was he
communicated with some of the great
scientists of the day through letters of
course and when word started spreading
of this discovery it just caught on like
wildfire it was like one of the biggest
things of the centuries or like the
structure of DNA is to the 20th century
regeneration of Hydra was a huge big
deal and so people in Britain people in
France all over the place we're
repeating his experiments to make sure
they were true and then eventually he
published this work in a journal called
the philosophical transactions of the
Royal Society where he was actually
invited to submit the work because
everyone was so excited and they
actually dedicated an entire issue to
this one topic so he got the cover
essentially and and I happened to have a
copy of that of that special issue of
the Royal of the transactions in which
his work was first published and so it's
mostly
mostly words of course but there are
some nice illustrations like this one
here of a Hydra bound stuck onto a twig
of some sort and then in this paper
which is written in English by the way
so it's actually totally readable in
this wonderful 18th century scientific
English it was translated from French by
someone at the Royal Society and and the
English is just a lot of fun to read and
it really captures every moment of the
discovery essentially every little thing
is described in wonderful detail and
right up to the point where he talks
about cutting it in half and and
observing over a period of days how
these two new Hydra would regenerate
from the two cut halves and so and then
this article is accompanied by
commentary from various other people
including at the front there's a letter
from the aristocrat count bin tink was
his name who whose estate he worked on
that's here at the front end and then
following the article are commentaries
from other famous scientists and so the
whole thing was a really major discovery
in the 18th century and created quite a
stir and then so this came out in about
17 43 this this article he was
immediately made a fellow of the Royal
Society because of this anyone there
they're coply metal which is their their
major award for science every year and
then in the year after that he published
this incredible book that came out about
a year after the the article in the
Philosophical Transactions in which he
summarized everything he had done with
Hydra over a period of two or three or
four years and so this books contains
all kinds of wonderful observations in
French of every little experiment every
observation he made about Hydra
beginning with the basic description of
the organism all the way through these
and incredible experiments in which he
cut it in pieces and analyzed
regeneration and analyzed all kinds of
other features of its behavior but this
book is not just great for its science
but also because it's one of the most
beautiful scientific books ever
certainly in the 18th century it's
considered one of the classics because
it contains so many beautiful
illustrations as well because he
recruited a friend of his to do these
copper engravings
of the Hydra and those copper engravings
are now considered to be among the most
gorgeous scientific illustrations ever
done and so you can see all these really
delicate little Hydra diagrams that were
drawn on copper plates of course these
are copper engravings and so this artist
by the name of Leo Mei was responsible
for producing these these engravings and
so this book is just filled with
gorgeous engravings of of Hydra in
various states it also includes
illustrations of the the famous
experiment where he cut the Hydra in
pieces way back here there's a figure
showing the two halves of a Hydra that's
being cut and then following the tail
half as it begins to regenerate at a
head essentially so and this in fact
this figure has all kinds of fun other
experiments where he he actually turned
Hydra inside out by inverting the inner
cells to come out onto the outer cells
and then observed what happened to those
cells so he was he was doing lots of
really interesting and innovative and
creative experiments and what's really
fun about the book is it also includes
illustrations of him at work including
this really classic engraving here
showing tremblay at work with the two
students on the other side of the table
and with little jars of Hydra all
sitting on the windowsill behind him and
the the grounds of the of the estate in
the window outside so it's really
captures this amazing moment in
scientific history when this guy was
doing all these experiments essentially
all by himself he communicated a lot by
letters with some of the famous
scientists of the day as I said but he
he was basically working on his own and
just having a great time for years
studying these organisms and so in a way
this book part of the appeal of this
book in fact is that it is sort of a
relic of a different era in science when
it was completely unfettered by by all
the modern issues that that have sort of
taken over in science issues of funding
and
institutions and career ISM and all the
other issues that now influence how
science is done this guy was doing pure
unfettered science and so this is a
great relic from that era so Tremblay
but the the amazing thing about him was
that this wasn't all he did he actually
also looked at a lot of other little
animals in the palms of the the estate
and that's where we get to cell division
so this was a bit of a sidetrack from
cell division but it's the the
foundation for what came next which is
that he started looking at protozoans as
well but he also called little animals
essentially that were essentially little
single-celled ciliates like vorticella
and and Stentor and some of the other
large single-celled protozoan ins that
are big enough that you can actually see
them through a magnifying glass because
he didn't actually use microscopes he
used really fancy high-powered
magnifying glasses and so when he
started looking at protozoans he
witnessed them dividing and and his
descriptions of that protozoan division
were published a couple years later also
in the Philosophical Transactions and so
i have copies of those as well of papers
in which there are basically two papers
one from 1744 and one from 1747 in which
Tremblay describes the the reproduction
he describes these little animals and
then describes how they divide and he
actually illustrates the division of
some of them so for example these these
communal Vorta salads like this guy
right here that which are are pretty
well understood organisms at this point
they have this little bell-shaped head
on them with a long tail and they divide
by like longitudinally dividing down the
middle essentially and then they form
into these communal multicellular
gatherings essentially in a way these
two papers here are really the first
description anywhere in detail of cell
division of any sort and so these are
are kind of the foundation stone for
first studies of cell division although
ironically as you know he he did not
know he was looking at cells because
this is 1740s and at that point cells
were considered something that were
probably existing
plants their importance as the
fundamental building block of all
organisms was not even close to
appreciated so it's an interesting case
of someone looking at something and
describing it in detail but not knowing
not having any idea really of what he
was seeing which I always like to think
about is it as a lesson for today as
well because a lot of us in the lab are
busily describing things in detail and
not really understanding them in a way
that we can possibly we will possibly be
able to understand you know hundreds of
years from now after Tremblay the the
next real wave of cell division work
came from various people mostly working
in the early 1800s another really fun
paper came along in 1824 from a pair of
French scientists called pre volt and
Duma who were the first to describe the
cleavage of the frog egg and and so
their illustrations that accompanied
their paper in this French journal
really provide a gorgeous illustration
of of the various stages in in frog
development all the way from a
fertilized egg all the way through the
various divisions up to the embryo and
so their description is clearly the
first really clear description of how
the how the fertilized egg subdivides
into parts as it as it becomes an embryo
but here again this is 1824 this is
before the cell theory really kicked
into gear and so they didn't appreciate
either what they were looking at they
had no idea that they were seeing the
formation of cells during each of these
subdivision processes and so it wasn't
until maybe ten years later her less
that people started realizing thinking
about I mean cells became much more
important at that point as a building
block and it was it was soon thereafter
that people started describing what
appeared to be cell reproduction in
multicellular organisms and so that was
another big major event or landmark in
in the history and the the person who's
generally regarded as the first person
to witness cell division in a
multicellular organism is this Belgian
scientist by the name of Doom or TA this
is an unusual copy because it's
presented by the author do Marty
to a colleague and so there's his
signature and he published this rather
large article in 1832 in which he
described a lot of different organisms
both animal and plant in which he was
just describing various aspects of their
biology and one minor little segment of
the paper he talks about this particular
filamentous algae called silk weed or
confirma in which he was observing cell
division at the very tip of the filament
and he provides a nice little
illustration of that cell division
process right here in this figure 15 of
the first plate so down there what he
says in the accompanying text is that
that cell a at the very end of the tip
elongates and then a wall forms right to
the middle of it
and and he then speculated that perhaps
this is how cells are produced by
division which was actually a fairly
heretical notion at the time and then
later in the 1830s when schleiden and
schwann and all the rest of the the big
german famous cell biologists came along
most people did not believe in cell
division they thought that cells were
reproduced by essentially being
crystallized in the medium surrounding
other cells or or perhaps they formed
inside cells and they were then ejected
and so that there is no there's a lot of
disagreement about how new cells formed
and this was the first clear evidence
that they formed by division and it was
then a lot of other people started
following up on this and seeing cell
division in other organisms then
eventually of course it took maybe 20 or
30 years before it became clear that all
cells divided by cell division and so by
the end of the 1850s essentially a
number of scientists were proclaiming
that that must be the way it is for all
cells and then there's just one last
little highlight I thought we should
always mention because anyone who knows
anything about cell division and often
times you see this guy in in research
talks because he is very famous for what
he did and that's a scientist by the
name of Walter Fleming who who is
essentially credited with sorting out
how mitosis works and how chromosome
duplicated chromosomes or sister
chromatids are segregated on the mitotic
in law and he has a ton of really
outstanding work in the late 1800s but
his major discovery was well before he
came along people had seen chromosomes
and they had seen these interesting
behaviors that chromosomes do during
mitosis but to most people these
chromosomes look just like blobs that
were sort of nondescript and then and
then these this big blob of chromosomes
would separate into two blobs of
chromosomes going to opposite ends of
the cell it was not clear at all of
course at that point that chromosomes
were that were the source of the
heritable material because genetics
hadn't even been really discovered at
that point but people realized that
those chromosomes must have something to
do with inheritance there must be some
indication but understanding how they
separated was really unclear until
Walter Fleming came along and he appears
to being really technically skilled with
various stains and fixation methods that
allowed him to see duplicated
chromosomes as individual threads and in
fact the word mitosis comes from the
word for thread because he he was the
first to see chromosomes sister
chromatids as separate chromatids and
that allowed him to to realize that
during mitosis chromosomes are
longitudinally split and moved to
opposite poles of the cell and so it's
not like some of them go in one
direction and some one go in the other
it's actually every chromosome is split
down the middle and moves to opposite
poles and that of course really set the
stage for genetics and inheritance a few
years later and so as I said he
published it a lot an awful lot of
different work on this subject and I
can't bring it all I haven't I have a
lot of it at home in various journals
and so on but I brought along the one
that really started really established
this idea of longitudinal division it
was published in this journal Carl
called the archive for microscopic
anatomy in Germany which was published
in these huge annual volumes this is
just one one volume they're all enormous
they're filled to the brim with
beautiful illustrations of all sorts
which is all sorts of different aspects
of microscopic anatomy all the way from
tissues down to single cells and
division and so on and
I actually one of my big mistakes as a
book collector is that I I for some
reason bought 72 volumes of this journal
and so my dining room currently has a
long bookshelf on it which has 70
versions of this of this thing taking up
an awful lot of space so these books are
filled with lots of nice illustrations
and and this is where Walter Fleming
published a lot of his major work and
what's fun about Fleming is that he was
obviously very meticulous about his
illustrations as he had to be to
describe this longitudinal splitting it
was important to be able to really show
clearly what was going on and so his his
images and his illustrations tend to be
among the most striking in the entire
journal and in fact among the most
striking of all cell biologists of the
time you know you can flip through a
journal like this and as soon as you
come to the most gorgeous beautiful
illustrations in the book you know
you've found the Fleming okay here's the
illustration that established the idea
of longitudinal splitting essentially
these two pictures right here show
chromosomes not as individual rods but
as a series of a pair of lines that are
longitudinally split and you can see in
a lot of other illustrations how how he
really emphasized this splitting of the
chromatids into two and so that those
illustrations really are the beginning
of our modern understanding of mitosis
and that of course is why so many people
love to use Fleming's illustrations as
as illustrations of my top mitotic
principles I would say that the
interesting thing about learning about
the history of the field like this is
that it really helps us understand what
we're doing today a lot of students
especially young people and I was the
same way to some extent don't really
find history very interesting because
they think it's all old stuff that's
being sorted out but but I found by
going through a lot of these old papers
and going through the old work
I can see issues there that are exactly
the same as what we deal with today
issues like how to do a good experiment
and what meticulous observation is worth
and how important good description is as
well not just experiments but good
description which
a lot of people poopoo these days of
course but also issues like
controversies between famous scientists
and one camp and famous scientists and
other and how in the end sometimes the
greatest scientists of a generation can
actually be wrong and that's always an
interesting thing to observe and there's
plenty of examples of that in this
history but in the end the important
thing is to to appreciate what a great
experiment is and even in the old days
abraham Tremblay sitting in this in this
house in the countryside of Holland was
doing really beautiful experiments that
were driven by pure creativity and
curiosity and we somehow have to capture
that in the science we do today as well
you